Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's eine Vanille-Buttercreme-Rosentorte!
Und ich persönlich finde Buttercreme kann sehr lecker sein wenn man ein paar Schritte beachtet,
es kann aber auch schnell nach hinten losgehen und dann kann Buttercreme auch einfach nur buttrig und schwer schmecken.
Ich zeig euch heute was für Tipps und Tricks ihr beachten müsst, damit das einfach *Mwah!* richtig lecker wird!
So! Dafür habe ich jetzt hier zuallererst meine Butter, die sollte zimmerwarm sein.
Ich hab sie jetzt vor ungefähr 3 Stunden hier auf die Arbeitsfläche gelegt und das genügt auch schon.
Sie darf auch nicht zu flüssig sein, also gerade im Sommer müsst ihr aufpassen.
Ähm - und es sollte einfach wirklich nur schön streichzart sein, sage ich mal.
So und die Butter gebe ich zusammen mit Salz und Vanilleextrakt - Das wird ja eine Vanille-Buttercreme! -
in meine Rührschüssel der Küchenmaschine. Ihr könnt aber auch alternativ gerne euer Handrührgerät benutzen.
Allerdings schlagen wir sie heute wirklich sehr lang, daher finde ich ist eine Küchenmaschine da immer am besten geeignet.
So, jetzt könnt ihr hier ganz gut erkennen: Ich hab das insgesamt über 8min geschlagen und das in der Küchenmaschine!
Mit dem Handrührgerät kann es sein, dass ihr da 1-2min länger braucht.
Und achtet dann auch drauf, ob es - Meistens ist es ja so, dass ihr da einen Kurzzeitbetrieb habt,
also könnt ihr dann das Handrührgerät nur 2min lang nutzen, müsst dann wieder warten und dann wieder 2min lang mixen.
Also achtet da einfach drauf damit ihr euch später nicht ärgert.
Und ich wollte euch gerne auch nochmal zeigen, wie jetzt der Farbunterschied ist.
Dafür habe ich hier nochmal unaufgeschlagene Butter grad aus dem Kühlschrank geholt
und zeige euch im Vergleich daneben unsere aufgeschlagene Butter.
Da sieht man auch schon den Farbunterschied und genau so muss sie eben sein
und jetzt geben wir Puderzucker noch mit dazu.
Fertig!
M-hm! Lecker, vanillig! Echt gut!
Ich hab auch noch ein bisschen Sahne hinzugefügt, das dient einfach damit die Textur noch cremiger wird.
Ich schreib euch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Und falls ihr denkt: "Boah, das war eine ganz schöne Menge an Puderzucker!"
Ich glaub wenn jetzt hier ein Amerikaner zugucken würde, der würd' sagen: "Ey, da muss noch viel, viel, viel mehr rein!"
Denn in amerikanischen Buttercremes kommt meist mehr als die doppelte Menge an Butter rein.
Und einerseits braucht man das natürlich für den Geschmack und andererseits auch für - damit es schön fest ist, also wirklich für den Stand.
Und daher können wir - also ich kann zwar Puderzucker reduzieren, aber nur bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt
Und das habe ich hier schon extrem, also wirklich in extremer Form reduziert.
Und ich find's so wirklich sehr lecker, sehr vanillig.
Natürlich ist Vanilleextrakt ausschlaggebend aber wenn ihr jetzt z.B. Zitronen-Buttercreme möchtet,
dann könntet ihr auch so ein bisschen Zitronensaft reingeben oder noch besser den Schalenabrieb einer Bio Zitrone.
Und jetzt ist auch die Textur für mich einfach per-fekt! Ich gebe das jetzt ganz kurz an die Seite.
Was ich nämlich auch schon vorbereitet hab - Ihr kennt ja meine Basics auf meinem Kanal - ist ein Schokoladenbiskuitboden.
Das ist dann der perfekte Ausgleich zur Buttercreme weil der Boden eben sehr, sehr, sehr locker-leicht ist
Meinen Schokobiskuitboden habe ich übrigens in einem Tortenring mit 20cm Durchmesser gebacken.
Da habe ich die gleichen Zutaten und Mengenangaben genommen, er brauchte allerdings 3min länger.
Aber ich schreibe euch sowieso alles Wichtige unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Grund war einfach der, dass ich die Böden gern so ein bisschen dicker hätte bei der Torte.
Und jetzt gebe ich den ersten Boden einmal auf eine schöne Servierplatte.
Ich geb da jetzt meinen Tortenring nochmal drumherum. Das hilft einfach, dass ich das schön gerade schichten kann.
Natürlich geht's auch ohne, denn wir entfernen den gleich sowieso direkt wieder, aber es ist einfach eine kleine Stütze.
Ich gebe der Torte innen jetzt noch so ein bisschen Pep indem ich Himbeerkonfitüre nehme um die Böden zu bestreichen,
die könnt ihr gerne kurz in der Mikrowelle erwärmen, dann lässt sie sich besser auf den Böden verstreichen.
Anschließend gebe ich noch frische Früchte mit dazu und ihr seht schon:
Der Boden ist sehr frisch und daher krümelt er auch ganz schön.
Daher ist es jetzt super wichtig wenn ihr ganz oben angekommen seid, einmal eine dünne Schicht Buttercreme auf die Oberfläche zu geben.
Das dient einfach der Krümelbindung und dass unsere Rosen später auch besser halten.
Jetzt ohne Kühlzeit etc. nehme ich auch schon den Tortenring ab, da nehme ich meinen Backformlöser.
Einfach drumherum fahren, abnehmen
und dann auch außen richtig schön dünn mit Buttercreme bestreichen damit wir die Krümel eben binden.
Und anschließend wird die Buttercreme eingefärbt.
Jetzt habe ich die Torte rundherum eingestrichen und sie muss auch gar nicht so schön und perfekt eingestrichen werden
denn das alles sieht man gleich sowieso nicht mehr!
Jetzt nehmen wir uns die restliche Buttercreme aber nicht zu viel!
Also immer nur das abschöpfen, was ihr für eine Schicht braucht.
Ihr könnt das ab der 2. Schicht auch sehr gut abschätzen aber hier eine Richtlinie:
Ich nehme mir jetzt so ungefähr 5 Esslöffel, vielleicht 6 Esslöffel von der Buttercreme weg und färbe sie schon mal ein.
Das, was übrig bleibt könnt ihr später noch mal mit heller Buttercreme vermengen.
Denn das Ziel ist es, erstmal eine Rosenreihe zu spritzen mit einer Sterntülle
und zwar dass die unterste quasi ganz, ganz, ganz rosa ist
und dann nach oben hin immer mehr ins rosé geht.
Ich persönlich finde immer, dass vom Farbverlauf her unten die satten Farben sein sollten.
Das könnt ihr natürlich auch entscheiden wie ihr möchtet.
Ihr könntet auch statt rosa jetzt blau, grün, lila und sonstwas nehmen.
Das ist einfach nur eine Inspiration für euch.
[Hamza] Also damit ich das verstehe: Du spritzt Rosen mit einer Sterntülle?
[Kiki] Ich spritze Rosen mit einer Sterntülle auf. Es gibt auch Rosentüllen..
[Kiki] ..aber ich finde optisch -
[Hamza] Also gute Frage von mir!
Ja, finde ich auch! Mega! Also es gibt auch Rosentülle aber mit einer Sterntülle
habt ihr's optisch einfach hübscher. Gerade bei so Torten wenn ihr die an den Rand spritzt.
Aber wir gucken gleich weil ich zeige euch das.
Das ist jetzt Lebensmittelfarbe.
Und zwar sind das Gelfarben, ich finde damit kann man immer am besten einfärben.
So, fertig ist die Rosentorte!
Ich finde sie extrem hübsch und wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, ist es auch extrem anfängergeeignet!
Denn die Buttercreme ist in nur 10min zusammengerührt und die Torte insgesamt
- Ich würde mal sagen wenn man sich Zeit lässt und ein bisschen trödelt,
dann ist sie in unter 2 Stunden komplett fertig.
Das Coole ist, dass die jetzt gekühlt extrem lange hält.
Dadurch, dass die Buttercreme jetzt auch quasi den Boden so ein bisschen konserviert,
hält die Buttercreme im Kühlschrank 5 Tage lang.
Das heißt ihr könnt 5 Tage lang daran essen oder sie auch gut vorbereiten.
Und ich rate euch: Wenn ihr sie dann serviert, nehmt sie ½h vorher aus dem Kühlschrank.
Ihr müsst wissen, dass die Buttercreme im Kühlschrank fest wird. Also nicht hart, sondern fest!
Wenn ihr sie eine halbe Stunde vorher rausnehmt, ist es per-fekt!
Ich würd' sagen ich persönlich verabschiede mich schon mal von euch!
Wer für Hamza's Taste Test dranbleiben möchte - Ich bin auch super gespannt übrigens, wie du den geschmacklich findest! -
der kann gerne dranbleiben! Und ansonsten -
[Hamza] Ich bin auch ehrlich, ich mag wie gesagt keine Buttercreme!
Das stimmt! Boah, Hamza mag eigentlich keine Buttercreme. Okay!
Hamza ist immer ehrlich - wir sind gespannt!
Ich an der Stelle sage schon mal: Tschüss! Bis zum nächsten Mal, eure Kiki!
[Kiki] Okay, wir haben's jetzt 1 Tag lang im Kühlschrank kühlen lassen
[Kiki] und ich finde auch, dass es dann so ein bisschen besser durchzuschneiden ist.
[Kiki] Jetzt steht er schon seit ½h hier, Hamza hat schon Bilder gemacht und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt! Eigentlich wollte ich dich alleine probieren lassen -
[Hamza] Ich glaub selbst wenn du die fotografiert hättest, das wär trotzdem hübsch geworden!
[Kiki] Ja, das glaub ich auch!
[Hamza] Weil die Torte ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schön!
[Kiki] Die ist wirklich sehr schön aber es kommt nicht nur aufs Äußere an!
[Hamza] Denn die inneren Werte zählen mehr!
[Kiki] Die inneren Werte zählen noch mehr!
[Hamza] Inneren Wert! Ich wollt's nochmal betonen: Innere Werte!
[Kiki] Ich bin so gespannt! Und bitte sei ehrlich!
[Kiki] Sag nicht nur weil ich es gemacht hab: "Oh, toll!" und so. Aber das bist du ja immer!
[Hamza] Okay, ich probier jetzt mal hier oben die erste Etage.
[Kiki] Ja?
[Kiki] Okay, da war auf jeden Fall eine Blaubeere mit drin.
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm!
[Kiki] Jetzt mit Himbeeren zusammen.
[Hamza] M-hm.
[Kiki] Erstmal möchte ich wissen: Schmeckt's buttrig? Schmeckst du richtig die Butter raus oder wie ist es?
[Hamza] Leicht! Ich finde -
[Kiki] Leicht? Okay, so ist es auch gewollt.
[Hamza] Man schmeckt auch bisschen den Puderzucker heraus. Also ich finde man schmeckt die Buttercreme raus, logisch.
[Hamza] Wie gesagt: Ich bin kein Buttercreme-Fan. Aber untere Note - dadurch, dass es unten so fruchtig ist.
[Hamza] Irgendwie gleicht das das aus, finde ich.
[Kiki] Genau!
[Kiki] Also wenn wir keine Früchte drin gehabt hätten, dann wär das glaub ich zu -
[Hamza] Dann wär das öde!
[Kiki] Öde, genau. Aber an sich -
[Hamza] Der Boden ist sowieso - der Boden ist hammer!
[Kiki] Also es ist halt wichtig, dass man mit den Komponenten spielt.
[Kiki] Dass man jetzt nicht so einen schweren Boden nimmt und dann noch irgendwie Schokolade statt Früchte mit rein nimmt.
[Kiki] Ja, ich gönn mir jetzt auch ein Stück zum Kaffee!
[Hamza] Man muss auch sagen an der Stelle: Das ist ein sehr schwerer Kuchen merke ich gerade!
[Hamza] Also ist ja Buttercreme-Kuchen, ne?
[Kiki] Ja! Mehr als ein Stück wird man auch glaub ich gar nicht schaffen!
[Hamza] Genau, das würd auf jeden Fall reichen!
[Kiki] Okay!
[Hamza] Willst du probieren?
[Kiki] Ja, gerne!
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] Und, wie feiern wir unsern Valentinstag?
[Kiki] Weiß ich gar nicht, was machen wir am Valentinstag?
[Hamza] Was sollen wir denn machen? Es ist Lockdown, man kann eh nicht raus!
[Kiki] Ich denk mal wir gucken einfach abends 'nen schönen Film!
[Hamza] Ja, auf jeden Fall! Irgend so 'nen Horrorfilm, ne?
[Kiki] Ja, auf jeden Fall! *lacht*[Hamza] Alles klar Leute!
[Hamza] Wir verabschieden uns und macht's nach. Sehr, sehr schön.
[Hamza] Für die, die zum ersten Mal backen ist es eigentlich sehr anfängerfreundlich würde ich sagen!
[Kiki] Ja! Definitiv, ja!
[Hamza] Überrascht euren Liebsten, euren Partner, eure Mama, euren Papa - egal wen!
[Hamza] Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schön!
[Kiki] Hast du schön gesagt!
[Kiki] Das waren schöne Schlussworte von dir!
[Kiki] Ich wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß beim Nachbacken und hoffe, dass ihr beim nächsten Video auch wieder dabei seid!
[Kiki] Bei 3, okay? 1,2,3!
[Hamza] Okay!
*beide* Tschüüüss!
[Kiki] Eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Euer Hamza!
[Hamza] Ich muss immer so 'ne hohe Stimme machen wenn ich das mache, wieso?
[Kiki] Ja, das gehört dazu!
[Hamza] Eure Kikiii!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] So Leute! Draußen stürmt's, wir essen Kuchen! Peace and out!
*beide lachen*